est ce que pour vous la france est
devenue de plus en plus violente oui la
france est devenue de plus en plus
jeunes et en plus avec une violence qui
est de plus en plus violente
je m'explique ouais à une époque quand
vous étiez pas d'accord avec quelqu'un
lors d'une soirée bon ça se friter comme
on dit c'est ça aujourd'hui on sort un
couteau
on sort une barre de fer vous avez un
cas comme ça très souvent maintenant ah
oui
ah oui y'a pas longtemps une fourche de
mobylette
ils se battent entre eux mais c'est
dramatique
ça fait problème vous êtes policier
pardon ça fait combien d'entrer dans la
police sa seizième temps est là depuis
quand vous avez senti vraiment que ça ça
bougeait en fait la violence a toujours
été présente
oui c'est ce qu'on voit là je suis dans
le sud actuellement mais à l'époque
quand j'étais en région parisienne c'est
vrai que c'était des frigos qui était
lancé des étages quoi d'accord et ça
c'était voilà c'est passé pour donc à
une dérive ou pas du tout alors où il ya
une dérive bien évidemment à presser
c'est c'est catastrophique
c'est vraiment catastrophique parce que
là on parle de choses que vous les
médias vous mettez en avant
maintenant il faut savoir que c'est
plusieurs fois par jour plusieurs fois
par jour alors on parle essentiellement
des grandes villes mais même dans les
petites villes
alors quel est l'événement le plus
choquant que vous ayez vu c'était je
crois que quand vous étiez en banlieue
parisienne
oui bon sens et mime est ce que j'aime
mon métier et on est tous à aimer notre
métier le problème c'est qu'on va crever
cyril on va crever parce qu'on nous
laisse tomber parce qu'on est détesté à
longueur de temps qui vous excusez moi
je réponds sur les ions alger d'accord
pourquoi on me traite de grosse [ __ ]
parce que je porte un uniforme mais
qu'est-ce qui me connaissent moi je suis
officier de police judiciaire
j'ai mis des pédophiles en prison
il me connaît celui qui me traite de
grosse [ __ ] je rappelle que vous avez
trois enfants vous êtes mère de famille
ils me connaissent et ckoi s'est
plusieurs fois par jour ça mais bien sûr
c'est plusieurs fois par jour et qu'est
ce qu'on fait ben on laisse tomber
pourquoi parce que la procédure pénale
est tellement dure a tellement longue
tellement tellement dur on est tellement
débordé de la procédure pénale qu'on va
pas aller encore emmerder les op j avec
un outrage
ben on laisse tomber vous regrettez
aujourd'hui
danone d'avoir été dans la police n'ont
pas fait non parce que quand vous avez
un petit bout de 4 ans qui vous dit
merci
quand il sort de votre bureau parce
qu'il a pu libérer sa parole que papy il
lui a fait du mal à la nénette
mais ça c'est la plus belle des
récompenses cyril c'est la plus belle
des récompenses
mais le problème qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est quand on nous insulte
aujourd'hui j'ai arrêté l'investigation
je suis depuis depuis à peu près un an
chaussures venus en tenue parce que j'en
pouvais plus suite à une dépression j'ai
passé ben j'ai une dépression envers la
suite à quoi
suite à tout ce que j'ai pu voir
qu'est-ce que vous avez parfois là qui
vous c'est quoi ces c'est moi j'oublie
quand une gamine de 13 ans vient vous
voir en vous disant pendant quatre
heures qu'elle nous raconte tout ce
qu'elle a subi pendant des années et
qu'elle vous dit qu'elle est on l'a
forcé à avoir un rapport sexuel avec le
chien oui cyril oui vous êtes là vous
rentrez chez vous ou tranquille tout va
bien non vous rentrez pas chez vous
tranquille tout va bien quand vous
arrivez sur une intervention qu'une
pauvre dame qui a fait un déni de
grossesse a accouché dans les toilettes
et que son enfant est mort dans les
toilettes
ils l'ont vécu ça et on me traite deux
buts après quand vous verbaliser une
famille parce que la gamine elle n'est
pas attachée derrière ils savent eux ils
ne savent mois que j'ai vu un gamin qui
acquis lors d'un accident à l'infini
dans le pare brise
quand vous allez chez des parents ou
chez une femme pour lui dire que son
mari est mort dans un accident de
voiture
ils le savent pas comment nous on leur
ont leur centre comment le rêve
j et après on traite de [ __ ] c'est tout
ce que vous avez vu c'est tout ce que
vous avez et numérique vous auriez plus
en énumérant pour on aimait numéraire et
toute la soirée cyril c'est ça qui a
fait que vous avez fait un burn-out
oui combien en faire et combien de
collègues se suicide
le problème c'est qu'on ne dit pas c'est
pas intéressant c'est pas intéressant et
le burn out vous avez arrêté combien de
temps de j'ai été arrêté un an un nom
oui un an j'ai été hospitalisé parce que
je pouvais plus
j'y arrivais plus qu'est-ce que vous
avez vos enfants comment ils l'ont pris
vous savez moi je l'avais dit ils ont
qu'à l'âge d'accord elles sont jamais
d'accord vous leur avez dit oui maman
maman et les malades c'est pas votre
faute
maman elle est fatiguée elle est malade
et vous avez eu le temps de réfléchir
vous avez le temps de prendre du recul
pendant un an
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous êtes
retourné après parce que j'aime saint
cyrille parce que j'aime aider parce que
j'aime mon métier parce qu'il faut pas
croire je suis pas là pour aller taper
sur quelqu'un je dénonce les violences
illégitimes
après je suis désolé mais quand vous
dites à quelqu'un
ben je vais te contrôler je vais vous
contrôlez et qui se débat
mais au bout d'un moment ci se laisse
contrôler il y aura pas de problème si
se laisse pas contrôler qui se débat b
ont fait honneur on est obligé
d'utiliser la violence
est-ce que vous avez conscience donc on
va le voir avec le témoignage de marc a
également qui a été victime de violences
de violences policières le mois dernier
encore est-ce que vous avez conscience
que des brebis galeuses chez vous vous
font peut-être beaucoup plus mal que les
personnes qui vous insultent parce que
ça cause de ces personnes là que vous
insultent derrière les cowboys comme on
dit qui cyril oui déco d'art y en a
partout
il y en a chez nous il y en a chez vous
il y en a partout d'école chez nous il y
en a 12 ou coupure il y en a partout
que les choses soient très claires
ensuite vous parlez du cowboy
ok il y en a qui font les cowboys c'est
vrai mais après c'est aussi une
technique pour prendre un ascendant sur
quelqu'un spar protection c'est pas tout
se la péter etc c'est pour pouvoir se
protéger aussi ce qu'on appelle figer la
situation